as you may have guessed it has been our
aim here tonight to choose our
presenters for their fitness for the
honor we also felt that if they were
good to look at that didn't hurt a bit
but to present the award for the best
achievement and direction the committee
has chosen the best-looking director in
town standing the poenas daughter must
have been born wise in the ways of show
business if there's anything of her
owner etiquette
she has lately added writing directing
and producing to her busy and
distinguished career as an actress
ladies and gentlemen miss Ida Lupino
the genie ever gave me a wish
I think I'd know how I'd spend it I want
my name to be in a list like this
those nominated for the best achievement
in directing are all the king's men
Robert Watson production Columbia
Robert Roslin battle bran
metro-goldwyn-mayer William a Wellman
the Fallen Idol London film productions
Selznick releasing organization British
Carroll read the eros paramount William
Wyler and a letter to three wives 20th
Century Fox Joseph L mankiewicz the
winner is Joseph L mankiewicz
although this is banquets first
combination for the right
of course he just got true
an award for the screen
for letter two three wives thank you
thank you brother Lupino Peppino's name
incidentally
on the membership list if the screen
Directors Guild is early P know that way
we can keep the same informal tone to
our meetings and and there's a building
cost to be considered ladies and
gentlemen this this is something for
which nobody and all honesty can be
prepared I am not prepared this is a
great honor and I am deeply appreciative
thank you
Thank You Ida Lupino and double
congratulations to you Jo mankiewicz